In House of the Dragon Episode 9, the king
is dead – and his body is not even cold
before his family starts fighting for his
throne.
This episode focusses on Alicent’s family,
the greens, in their plots to make Aegon king.
So what happens, and what does it mean?
This video has no spoilers for future episodes,
except for some minor background info.
The opening sequence family tree has been
updated.
The symbol for King Viserys is now flooded
with blood to show that he’s dead.
The symbol for Alicent Hightower now shows
the Hightower sigil within the star of the
Faith of the Seven – cause Alicent now wears
that religious symbol.
Alicent’s daughter Helaena has a symbol
of a spider, cause Helaena likes bugs, and
she stitches a spider picture this episode.
Aegon’s symbol looks like a woman and a
dragon egg.
And Aemond’s symbol is a sapphire – in
the books, Aemond wears a sapphire in his
empty eye socket.
The bloodlines also show that Alicent has
a fourth child who we haven’t seen yet – a
son named Daeron.
The author George Martin said they couldn’t
fit Daeron into this season of Hot D, but
Daeron will appear in Season 2 –for now,
Daeron is in OIdtown serving Lord Hightower
as cupbearer, so his symbol is a cup.
Aegon now has three children with Helaena
– a girl named Jaehaera, and a boy named
Jaehaerys, and a boy named Maelor.
In the books, Jaehaerys has six fingers on
one of his hands, and six toes on each foot,
so Jaehaerys and Jaehaera’s symbols are
six-fingered hands.
The first person to discover that King Viserys
is dead is this servant boy.
With his blonde hair, he kinda looks like
a Targaryen – this episode reveals that
Aegon has some bastard children, so we might
wonder if this boy is a secret Targaryen bastard…
Or he’s just blonde.
The boy tells Talya that the king is dead.
So Talya tells Queen Alicent.
But then Talya lights some candles in a window
as a signal to tell Mysaria that the king
is dead.
Because Talya is a spy for Mysaria, and Mysaria
can use this information to her advantage
by kidnapping Prince Aegon.
Alicent believes that Viserys wanted their
son Aegon to be king.
And that’s not true, Alicent misunderstood
Viserys’ words, but she believes this is
her husband’s dying wish.
We see Alicent’s grief for Viserys, this
is deeply personal for her.
But at council, Alicent sees that Otto Tyland
and Jasper don’t care about Viserys’ wishes.
Cause they were already plotting to crown
Aegon, secretly scheming behind Alicent’s
back.
They plan to make the City Watch loyal to
them, they’ll move the crown’s gold for
safekeeping, they plan alliances with the
Tullys, Tyrells and Baratheons.
And they don’t include Alicent in their
plans.
Alicent had thought that as the queen they
respected her enough to include her – but
apparently not.
Alicent learns that Otto plans to kill Rhaenyra,
so that Rhaenyra can’t challenge Aegon,
and Alicent is outraged – for all her disagreements
with Rhaenyra, she doesn’t want Rhaenyra
murdered.
She wants to honour her dead husband’s wishes.
So Alicent and Otto both want Aegon to be
king, but while Otto is willing to murder,
Alicent wants a peaceful transition.
And this is a change from the books.
In the books, Alicent doesn’t protect Rhaenyra,
in fact she reportedly hopes that Rhaenyra
will die in childbirth.
The show makes Alicent more peaceful and sympathetic.
The books also include more specific arguments
over the succession, like Otto says they can’t
let Rhaenyra be queen, cause she’s married
to Daemon, and Daemon would be a terrible
cruel king consort who might kill them all.
Jasper says Aegon should be king because of
succession laws that put men before women,
and cause the Harrenhal Council chose the
male Viserys over the female Rhaenys.
While Criston says Rhaenyra should not rule
because she’s a slut who will who will make
the Red Keep a big slutty brothel.
Criston is.. still really butthurt about his
rejection by Rhaenyra.
The only one to stand up for Rhaenyra is Lyman
Beesbury.
Lyman often seemed a weak and irrelevant old
man.
But he refuses to go along with this coup
– he says Viserys always said that Rhaenyra
was his heir, and they can’t change the
succession based on Alicent’s word that
he changed his mind on his deathbed.
Lyman hints that Viserys may have been murdered
– in the books, Mushroom claims that Alicent
poisoned Viserys.
Criston is angered by the insult to Alicent.
So he slams Lyman down, and Lyman is killed,
with a stone council ball to his head.
In the books, there are three different stories
of how Lyman dies.
Eustace says that Criston cut Lyman’s throat.
Mushroom says that Criston threw Lyman out
a window.
And Orwyle says that Lyman was just imprisoned,
and then died of a chill.
The book Fire & Blood plays with unreliable
narration, rumour and bias twist the truth.
Orwyle is one of the historical sources for
this part of the book, and Orwyle sometimes
lies to make himself look good.
Harrold says Criston should be removed from
the Kingsguard for murdering Lyman.
Just as he previously murdered Joffrey Lonmouth.
But Alicent protects Criston because he’s
useful to her.
The Kingsguard are meant to be a sacred brotherhood
of noble knights – not murderers helping
to steal the Throne.
So Harrold is outraged that the Kingsguard
are being corrupted by politics.
Otto tells Harrold to go and arrest Rhaenyra.
But Harrold was Rhaenyra’s friend and protector
since she was a kid.
He won’t give her to the greens to be murdered.
He doesn’t accept their authority – cause
he’s sworn to serve the king, and there
is no king.
So Harrold removes his cloak and leaves, kinda
like when Barristan leaves in Game of Thrones.
Maybe Harrold will turn up again later to
support a different ruler, like Barristan
does.
The greens are ready to make Aegon the new
king.
But Aegon is missing, so Alicent and Otto
race to find him.
Alicent hopes that if she finds Aegon first,
she’ll be able to influence Aegon, and make
sure the succession happens peacefully without
hurting Rhaenyra.
She could even make Aegon remove Otto as Hand
of the King, or hold Aegon hostage.
As Renly says in Game of Thrones, “he who
holds the king holds the kingdom”.
In the books, Tyrion and Cersei both try to
capture Tommen for themselves.
Sometimes the king is used as a pawn in the
game of thrones.
Otto sends the twins Ser EErryk and Ser AArryk
to find Aegon.
While Alicent sends Criston and Aemond.
The teams race across the city searching for
clues to find Aegon – it’s like The Amazing
Race, and the prize is a drunk prince.
Alicent tells Helaena and Aemond that their
father Viserys is dead.
Alicent tries to comfort Helaena, but she
pulls away – Alicent’s children are difficult
to love.
Otto and Alicent want the king’s death to
stay secret until they’re ready to take
power.
So they round up servants and lords at the
Keep, and lock them up so they can’t blab
to Rhaenyra.
Rhaenys is locked in her room.
Otto makes the lords swear to support Aegon.
These aren’t, like, all the lords in Westeros,
it’s just the minor lords who happened to
be in the Red Keep today.
Most of them agree to support Aegon.
But Lord Merryweather and Lady Fell refuse.
House Merryweather rules Longtable in the
Reach.
And House Fell rules Fellwood in the stormlands.
Merryweather and Fell are old enough that
they were probably at the ceremony years ago
when everyone swore to support Rhaenyra as
heir.
So they refuse to break their oath by supporting
Aegon, so Otto imprisons these loyalists.
Lord Allun Caswell wants to support Rhaenyra
– we’ve seen him friendly with Rhaenyra
before – so Allun pretends to support Aegon,
but then he tries to escape the Keep to go
tell Rhaenyra that the greens are stealing
her throne – but Allun is captured, and
Otto and Larys put Allun to death.
Allun is hanged in the Keep courtyard as a
warning to other rebels.
Alicent asks Rhaenys to support her.
Rhaenys is effectively in charge of the powerful
House Velaryon, and Rhaenys has the great
dragon Meleys.
So Rhaenys could be a powerful ally for Aegon
and the greens.
Alicent says that allying with Rhaenyra and
Daemon has only hurt Rhaenys and her family.
Alicent says Rhaenys should have been the
queen of Westeros.
But since Rhaenys and Alicent can’t rule
the realm themselves, they should instead
influence King Aegon and the council, gently
guiding the kingdom towards peace.
But Rhaenys says that’s bullshit.
She and Alicent don’t have real power when
they’re serving men.
Like, Rhaenys told Corlys for years that his
ambitions put their children in danger, but
he didn’t listen and now their children
are dead.
Alicent is the queen, yet even she doesn’t
have power when it matters – like when the
men take over the succession and plot murder
and war without her.
So Rhaenys says that gentle female influence
within this patriarchy is just a window in
their prison cell, it’s an illusion, and
the only real power is taking the Throne itself.
And that’s what Rhaenyra wants to do.
Unlike Alicent, Rhaenyra has always resisted
the rules of sex and gender.
She wants to be the first woman on the Throne,
she said she’ll create a new order.
Rhaenys doesn’t much believe in Rhaenyra
either.
She told Rhaenyra that she’ll fail to change
the system.
Rhaenys’ actor says that after Rhaenys’
own failure to take the Throne, she almost
wants to believe that the patriarchy can’t
be touched, that no woman will truly rule
Westeros.
But Rhaenys is impressed by Alicent’s determination
for peace.
She maybe feels hope as well as cynicism and
resentment, and feels fear that this this
conflict may cause more death.
Criston and Aemond search for Aegon.
Aemond wears a hood and Criston wears a hat,
as though they’re cosplaying Rhaenyra and
Dameon in Episode 4.
They go to a brothel that Aemond and Aegon
had visited as teenagers.
A woman there recognises Aemond, and he seems
embarrassed – maybe he lost his virginity
with this woman, maybe he feels ashamed, we
don’t know much about Aemond’s sexuality.
But Aegon isn’t here.
So Aemond says Aegon could be captured, or
dead, or on a ship to Yi Ti.
Yi Ti is a powerful empire in the far east,
inspired by Imperial China.
Corlys Velaryon is one of the few Westerosi
who have been to Yi Ti on his famous voyages.
HBO is developing an animated spin-off show
about Yi Ti, called The Golden Empire.
Aemond is mad that Aegon gets to be king,
when Aegon is an irresponsible asshole.
Aemond studies hard and trains so that he
thinks he should be king.
Aemond says that he is next in line for the
Throne.
Which is not true – legally, Aegon’s children
are his heirs, before his brother Aemond.
Though there is a fan theory that Aemond might
actually be the father of Helaena’s children,
that they have a secret incestuous love affair.
There have been several sibling love triangles
in the books, this a classic Targaryen move.
And Aemond has shown interest in Helaena before.
While Aegon mostly ignores Helaena.
And if Aemond was secretly the father of Helaena’s
children, then Aemond would legally be Aegon’s
heir.
But that’s just a wild theory.
The point is that Aemond has that jealous
second son syndrome that we’ve seen in Daemon
and Vaemond, wanting what their older brother
has.
Helaena says this episode that it’s human
nature to be envious of what others have – envy
is a big motivation for many characters in
this story.
Criston understands how Aemond feels.
Because Criston is a lower-class person who’s
had to work harder for his status on the Kingsguard
compared to the rich privileged sons of lords.
Criston resents Rhaenyra for her privilege,
he once called her a spoiled c-word – which
is funny, cause in this episode he says that
all women should be respected.
Criston is both chivalrous, and misogynistic
– he uses his image as a noble white knight
to hide his hateful nature.
Aemond says that he and Criston are “decent
men with no taste for depravity”, which
is nonsense, cause Criston killed a man just
this morning.
He once beat a man to death at a wedding.
But the rules of honour and chivalry in this
world allow bad people to call themselves
righteous.
Alicent does the same thing, using her cloak
of righteousness to hide her jealousy and
hate.
Aemond and Criston can’t find Aegon because
they don’t know where Aegon hangs out.
But Ser Erryk is Aegon’s sworn protector,
his personal guard.
So Erryk knows that Aegon often visits this..
child fighting pit.
Here, children with sharp filed teeth fight
each other for entertainment.
This is the deep dark underbelly of King’s
Landing, and Aegon participates in this evil.
Aegon has a bastard child who he leaves here
in the pit, not exactly father of the year.
Aegon’s a monster, and yet they’re making
him king.
Erryk says that Aegon is unfit to rule, they
shouldn’t support him as king.
But his twin Arryk wants to keep his oath
and stay loyal to Aegon.
A woman called Jeyne reveals that Mysaria
has Aegon, so Otto meets with Mysaria.
Mysaria has worked with Otto before as a spymaster,
but this is the first time Otto’s met the
White Worm in person.
Mysaria says she has Aegon hostage, and she
could kill him.
She’ll release Aegon if Otto ends the use
of children in fighting pits.
We know that Mysaria was once a slave.
We see a scar on Mysaria’s neck, she has
suffered.
So Mysaria sympathises with these exploited
children, and wants them freed.
Or perhaps to use the kids in her child spy
network – seems hypocritical that she also
uses kids.
But Otto says he’ll look into the fighting
pits, and Mysaria tells him where Aegon is.
Mysaria might not trust Otto to actually close
the fighting pits, Mysaria has been betrayed
and let down before, this is more about sending
a message.
Mysaria tells Otto that the common people
are powerful.
And if Otto and King Aegon don’t treat the
people right, there will consequences.
In Game of Thrones we see the power of the
people in riots and uprisings.
Erryk and Arryk find Aegon in the sept.
It’s ironic to find this drunk depraved
asshole in a holy sacred place.
But before they can take Aegon to Otto, they’re
stopped by Criston and Aemond, who wanna take
Aegon to Alicent.
Arryk fights Criston, but his brother Erryk
just watches and does nothing.
Erryk doesn’t want to help crown the monstrous
Aegon, and he realises he can’t change Arryk’s
mind.
So Erryk leaves to support Rhaenyra instead.
This conflict is dividing families, even putting
these twins on opposite sides.
Aegon tells Aemond to let him go, so Aegon
can flee the country.
Aegon doesn’t want to be king, he says he’d
be a terrible king, and Aemond agrees.
But Aegon is the eldest son, so his family
drags him kicking and screaming onto the Throne.
So Alicent captures Aegon, she wins the game.
And now that she holds the prince, she controls
the succession.
She tells Otto they won’t kill Rhaenyra,
they’ll make Rhaenyra a good peace offer,
so Rhaenyra and her family can go into exile
in the east, like Daenerys and Viserys did
in Game of Thrones.
Alicent will make Criston the Commander of
the Kingsguard Commander to replace Harrold,
and they’ll crown Aegon King of Westeros.
The scene is shot to mirror a scene from Episode
1.
Back then, Otto totally controlled Alicent
– he pushed her into marrying Viserys, and
made her the queen.
But now, Alicent finally sees how much Otto
manipulated her for his goals.
Now, after years of obedience Alicent finally
rebels against her father and takes charge
as her own power.
And Otto’s reaction is to say that Alicent
looks like her mother.
It’s like in Episode 1, when he tells Alicent
to wear her mother’s dress to comfort Viserys.
Alicent is trying to assert herself as a political
equal here – but Otto makes it about her
appearance as a woman.
He also says that Alicent’s reluctance to
kill Rhaenyra is “squeamishness”, as though
Alicent is too delicate a lady to do a murder.
He doesn’t understand that Alicent’s mercy
is a serious moral and political decision,
not a weakness.
Like Rhaenyra with Viserys, Alicent is frustrated
that her father still sees her just as his
little girl, not as an equal.
Larys finds out that Mysaria has spies in
the Red Keep – people like Talya and that
blonde kid telling Mysaria important secrets.
And Otto has been allowing this, so he can
benefit from the spying.
Alicent doesn’t trust Mysaria or Otto at
this point, so she asks Larys to kill Mysaria,
and Larys sends one of his fireflies to burn
Mysaria’s house.
Last time Larys burned people, Alicent was
shocked and horrified.
But now, she’s asking Larys to murder people
for her.
Alicent is slowly embracing Larys’ evil.
And Larys might be manipulating Alicent.
Earlier, he seemed to offer to spy on Alicent
for Otto.
He’s playing both sides.
And we still don’t know how Larys found
out about Rhaenyra’s moon tea.
Maybe Larys is actually working with Mysaria
and her spies.
We don’t see if Mysaria dies in that fire,
maybe Larys let her go.
Larys’ true motivations are a mystery.
But we do know one thing – he likes feet.
As payment for his services, Alicent shows
Larys her bare feet for him to masturbate
to.
This seems to be an ongoing thing, Larys gives
secrets and does murders so Alicent shows
him feet.
Since Larys has a deformed foot himself it
kinda makes sense that he’s into nice feet.
And it’s not just about sex.
Larys enjoys having power over people, making
them uncomfortable, like those prisoners previously.
Maybe after a lifetime of being disrespected
for being disabled, Larys enjoys dominating
others, and humiliating the queen would be
the ultimate power trip.
We get a nice brooding montage as the characters
contemplate their awful decisions.
And Erryk frees Rhaenys.
Erryk wants to help Rhaenyra’s side instead
of Aegon.
So Erryk and Rhaenys escape through one of
the Keep’s secret passages.
Rhaenys stares at the skull of Balerion – a
reminder of the power, danger and death they
are risking in this conflict.
On the way out, Rhaenys is caught up in a
flood of people heading for the Dragonpit.
The greens herd the common folk like sheep
toward the Dragonpit for Aegon’s coronation.
Alicent takes Aegon to his coronation, and
Aegon says the truth – that Viserys obviously
didn’t want Aegon to be king, because Viserys
didn’t like Aegon.
After Aegon stopped being a cute baby, Viserys
seemed to ignore his son – except to occasionally
shout at him – so of course Viserys didn’t
choose Aegon to be king – Aegon laughs at
the absurdity of it.
Though as he laughs, he also feels the pain
of his father’s rejection.
Aegon is a lot like Tyrion in the later books
– Tyrion also feels rejected and unloved,
and also does horrible things in the books.
Alicent gives Aegon the Valyrian steel knife
that was once Aegon the Conqueror’s.
This knife symbolises the huge responsibility
of the Throne, it represents the prophecy
that the Targaryens must be united to defeat
the white walkers.
Aegon doesn’t even know about this prophecy,
he is not ready for this responsibility.
Alicent tells Aegon that as king, he should
not be cruel, and he should not kill Rhaenyra.
But Aegon doesn’t listen, Aegon never listened
to Alicent.
He’s never cared about other peoples’
feelings, Aegon is a rapist who leaves his
own children in fighting pits, he shouldn’t
be king.
But his mother Alicent blindly pushes him
into politics, just like Otto pushed Alicent
into politics.
All Aegon wants is love – he asks Alicent
if she loves him, and she calls him an imbecile.
The Dragonpit is big open space, well fortified
against attack, so it’s where the greens
hold Aegon’s coronation.
This is where the royal kids had dragon lessons
previously – the Targaryen dragons are kept
in tunnels below.
With much pomp and pageantry, Aegon comes
to claim his crown.
The grandeur of the ceremony contrasts with
the ugly depravity that brought Aegon here.
Septon Eustace anoints Aegon with the seven
holy oils of the Faith of the Seven.
Septon Eustace is one of the main historical
sources in Fire & Blood, alongside Mushroom
and Orwyle.
Aegon wears the crown of Aegon the Conqueror.
Aegon’s crown is made of Valyrian steel
decorated with rubies.
Which is different to the crown worn by Viserys
and Jaehaerys before him.
That crown is gold, decorated with sigils
of the houses of Westeros.
It symbolises peace and unity.
While Aegon the Conqueror’s crown is more
warlike.
Aegon also wears the Conqueror’s knife,
and the Conqueror’s legendary Valyrian steel
sword Blackfyre.
These are important symbols of legitimacy.
Varys says that “Power resides where men
believe it resides”.
And men believe that whoever has the king’s
crown, and the sword, and is anointed by the
septon, and has the name Aegon Targaryen and
blond hair, and is a firstborn son, and is
in King’s Landing with the Iron Throne – that
man is the rightful king, as far as most people
are concerned.
When Aegon is crowned, he looks to his family.
He gets a nod from Alicent.
Helaena looks unhappy, she doesn’t wanna
be queen, and Aemond looks jealous cause he
wants the throne.
But then Aegon looks to the common folk – and
the people cheer for him, and Aegon loves
it.
Aegon feels rejected by his family, he’s
desperate for affection, and suddenly he gets
a wave of love from people, it’s the validation
he’s always wanted.
So all of a sudden, Aegon might decide he
wants to be king after all.
Maybe the love of the people will change Aegon,
maybe he'll actually try to be a good king.
Though there’s a similar scene in Game of
Thrones where Joffrey discovers the love of
the common people.
And that didn’t make Joffrey a good person.
This moment of triumph for the greens is rudely
interrupted by a dragon.
Rhaenys had sneaked down into the pit to get
her dragon Meleys.
And she decides to escape by bursting up through
the floor of the Dragonpit, killing a lot
of innocent common people.
Rhaenys faces the greens, and she almost decides
to kill them all, to end their power grab.
But Rhaenys looks into Alicent’s eyes, sees
her protecting her son Aegon.
The greens are Rhaenys’ cousins.
Does she really want to murder her extended
family, after Rhaenys has recently lost her
own children, and her husband lies wounded?
Alicent had told Rhaenys that she wants peace.
So Rhaenys gives peace a chance.
She lets the greens live, and flies off – stomping
several more common folk in the process.
So Rhaenys shows mercy to the greens, but
massacres innocent people like it’s nothing.
Many lords and ladies don’t much care about
the lives of peasants.
When the lords play their game of thrones,
it’s always the innocent people who suffer.
Especially when dragons are involved.
Previously, we saw Daemon’s dragon stomp
on one of his own soldiers.
In Game of Thrones, Daenerys’ dragons eat
children.
Viserys said that dragons are a dangerous
uncontrollable power.
And whenever the Targaryens use their dragons,
innocent people die.
The Targaryens might not think that matters.
But Mysaria warned us of the power of the
people.
So Rhaenys’ mass murder may have consequences.
Aegon’s coronation fulfils Viserys’ prophecy
about his son being king, wearing Aegon’s
crown.
And Meleys bursting up through the floor fulfils
Helaena’s prophecy about a beast beneath
the boards.
But there are deeper meanings.
Like the beastly Aegon is found beneath an
altar in a sept.
Beneath the grand ceremony of the coronation
is the political corruption of the greens.
Beneath the power of the Targaryen dragons
are hidden beasts – Mysaria and Larys are
symbolised by worms and fireflies, spiders
and bees and wasps are also mentioned this
episode.
With their hidden passages and deadly secrets,
they too are beasts beneath the boards.
Daemon said that everyone is capable of depravity.
We’ve seen the violence beneath Alicent’s
courtesy, beneath Criston’s chivalry, beneath
Otto’s cold politics.
As this conflict gets worse, what other beasts
will emerge from below?
If you wanna know the full story of Hot D,
you’ve gotta check out the book, Fire & Blood.
There’s also the main series of Game of
Thrones books, and the worldbook, and Dunk
& Egg.
You can get any one of these on audiobook
for free right now at audible.com/asx.
Sign up for a Premium Plus trial membership,
and you get an audiobook to keep, even if
you cancel the trial.
You can get any Game of Thrones book, or Lord
of the Rings, or Dune.
Membership also includes unlimited access
to thousands of audiobooks and shows in the
Audible Plus Catalog.
Sign up at audible.com/asx, or text asx to
500-500.
Thanks for watching, please like and subscribe.
Thank you to the Patrons, including Matias
Holm Hansen, Robert, Harry Truscott, Hendo,
Andrew Lynch, Rohit Yarlagadda, and Gabby
Joy.
Cheers.